[Musique]
quel est le rapport entre la motivation
et un oreiller pour vous donner un
indice cet oreiller
c'est celui qui nous a tous retenus à un
moment dans notre vie au fond de notre
lit celui qui te dit on remédie minutes
sur le réveil j'ai pas envie d'y aller
pour tout vous avouer mon oreiller moi
avons l'entente était très proche
le problème de cette relation c'est que
tous les matins il faisait une scène
j'ai finalement réussi à mon éloignés
comment et bien grâce à l'objet de mes
études et de ma passion le cerveau j'ai
appris comme organisant autour de lui je
pouvais sortir de cette relation
compliquée nous nous rien n'a donc plus
le pouvoir
par contre plus j'explore le monde
plus je me rends compte qu'il ya des
problèmes avec des oreillers un petit
peu trop insistant vous vous donnez les
moyens de repousser leur avance je vais
partager avec vous aujourd'hui des
moyens efficaces pour être motivés et
transmettre la motivation
concrètement il ya deux approches
prendre soin de son cerveau et de celui
des autres pour débuter ce voyage je
vais vous raconter comment j'ai appris à
connaître et à prendre soin de cette
merveilleuse machine
c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert le
moyen d'être motivés et cette recette
pour la motivation je vous la
transmettre aujourd'hui en tout cas une
partie
tout commence avec mes études pour
obtenir mon master avec mention j'ai
décidé d'organiser toute ma vie autour
de lui
cette organisation forcément nécessite
quelques planification et bien tous les
matins je me levais à cette heure tous
les soirs je me couchais à 23 heures
autour de huit heures de sommeil notre
cerveau est en forme
c'est à cette période là que mon sermon
oreiller moi nous sommes séparés je vous
rassure on a gardé de bons rapports
1 la preuve faisait des siestes avec lui
en début d'après-midi pour booster mon
efficacité si vous pouvez intégrer les
siestes à votre emploi du temps fait le
même cinq minutes par jour c'est de
l'énergie en barre en parlant
d'alimentation j'ai essayé de manger
équilibré
pas facile en tant qu'étudiant un
l'equilibre consistait surtout à choisir
entre riz pâtes et patates
bon on va dire que au moins j'ai apporté
des sucres lents à ma matière grise
c'est déjà ça comme tout un chacun
vous allez le voir je faisais donc s'y
est jamais les sucres lents mais je
faisais aussi du sport 1 pour
m'entretenir footing et boxe
thaïlandaise toutes les semaines c'est
bien beau tout ça mais là dedans la vie
sociale elle est où eh bien je la
cultivaient au quotidien avec les
passions que j'accompagnais avec les
professionnels que je côtoyais et avec
les personnes que je rencontrais ces
exemples sont personnelles mais les
principes sont généralisable si vous
voulez si vous équilibrez le sommeil la
nourriture le sport la vie sociale vous
avez les quatre piliers pour développer
la motivation alors le problème de ces
quatre piliers ce qu'ils peuvent être
balayés par une force obscure
je veux bien sûr parler des émotions
négatives comme beaucoup j'ai vécu un
grand stress dans ma vie tous les jours
j'avais des aigreurs d'estomac
j'avalais des tablettes de médicaments
et pour autant la douleur ne partait pas
pour m'en sortir j'ai utilisé la
cohérence cardiaque quotidiennement pour
me relaxer la cohérence cardiaque donc
ça ça permet de diminuer le taux de
cortisol qui est l'hormone du stress
seulement en respirant simple et
utilisable par tous
pour approfondir le travail j'ai décidé
d'entraîner mon cerveau à se concentrer
sur le positif
oui important parce que d'habitude si on
se concentre sur le négatif de manière
automatique
eh bien nous allons avoir des grosses
difficultés est donc le stress que
j'évoquais juste avant hockey est bien
là avec cet entraînement j'ai pu
reprendre le contrôle de mon attention
et nous pouvons tous le faire et ça nous
pouvons le faire avec un autre outil la
méditation en pleine conscience
la méthode du docteur kabat zinn lesieu
en eau est bien appuyé par les
neurosciences depuis plus de dix ans
elle permet d'aborder la vie autrement
aujourd'hui
fini les aigreurs et les médicaments
place à l'énergie et la motivation
cette motivation nous pouvons la
renforcer en prenant soin notre servent
pour moi c'est comme élever un chien
donnez lui des quatre piliers une bonne
éducation
il peut vous sauver la vie si vous vous
noyez privé le maltraiter le il risque
de vous mordre
bon cette morsure cérébrale a va
s'orienter vers vous dans un premier
temps c'est le stress que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure mais elle va aussi se
diffuser vers les autres c'est ce qu'on
appelle la contagion émotionnelle
cette contagion émotionnelle c'est
lorsque nous vivons des émotions elles
vont se transmettre à notre entourage
même à l'insu de notre plein gré vous
comprenez maintenant pourquoi il faut
prendre soin de son cerveau avant de
gérer celui des autres les autres comme
le disait brel et bien parlons-en
nous aurons tous à motiver quelqu'un
dans notre vie au moins en tant que
parent ou en tant qu'ami nous sommes
donc tous des neuro manager en puissance
que ce soit pour les enfants ou les
collaborateurs le devoir du nouveau
manager c'est de prendre soin d'eux oui
prendre soin d'eux et ça c'est ce que
commencent à faire de grandes
entreprises comme adidas ou la poste
il crée des coins détente comme celui ci
est il crée aussi une organisation du
travail qui permet des siestes
intéressant autre exemple nous avons la
mairie de poissy donc là du côté
institutionnel
nous avons la mairie de poissy qui a
intégré sur le temps de travail de ses
agents
deux heures de sport par semaine c'est
pas mal mais ne rompt manager un autre
devoir celui de motiver et bien sûr de
diminuer le stress
pas facile mais possible est ce que vous
connaissez l'ergonomie
oui alors pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas c'est adapter son environnement de
travail pour éviter que le corps souffre
ici nous allons parler de neuro
ergonomie adaptée son environnement ses
comportements pour éviter que le cerveau
souffre alors l'intérêt de la neuro
ergonomie c'est que la plupart des
changements apportés sont gratuits oui 0
euros à investir et vous y gagnez en
bien-être et en productivité
ah je vois des regards s'allumer dans le
public
dès qu'on parle d'argent les cerveaux
serait rien eh bien profitons-en pour
aborder le premier principe la
motivation par la personnalisation
imaginez que vous puissiez assouvir
votre passion sur votre temps de travail
eh bien ça certains employés chez apple
peuvent le faire ils ont deux semaines
par an pour leurs projets personnels
cette pratique nous pouvons tout cela
mettre en place en tant que nouveau
manager la conséquence directe c'est
bien sûr des émotions positives une
envie d'y revenir naturellement la
motivation elle va grandir et se
présenter dès le saut du lit
deuxième principe la motivation par la
récompense
alors je vous entends penser d'ici nous
a dit que ça l'est rien écouté et là il
dit faire des cadeaux attendez la suite
vous verrez que je tiens parole les
récompenses avec la passion c'est ça qui
nous fait être motivé c'est ça qui nous
fait lâcher notre oreiller
nous sommes motivés parce qu'on sait ce
qui va arriver pendant et après
l'activité
pour vous donner un secret la plus belle
des récompenses nous la possédons tous
nous pouvons tous faire preuve de
considération
nous pouvons tous félicités et soutenir
nous pouvons tous valoriser le travail
ou la réalisation d'un objectif
vous l'aurez compris la plus belle des
récompenses elle se situe dans les mots
et dans les comportements du neuro
manager problème c'est quand les des
motivateurs apparaissent les des
motivateurs c'est mon troisième et
dernier principe et il y en a deux
groupes
quand vous n'avez pas ça et bien vous
allez arriver à un autre groupe les
comportements direct les des motivateurs
se sont l'hypocrisie l'inéquité et la
critique sur la personne
le deuxième groupe ce sont les
obligations indirects changer trop
fréquemment d'objectifs imposer des
règles aux inutiles et inciter la
compétition permanente c'est des
motivateurs ce sont comme les balles
d'un pistolet comme celui ci la menace
de leur utilisation
c'est un braquage permanent imaginez
cette sensation tous les jours imaginez
cette épée de damoclès prête à tomber
j'irai même plus loin l'utilisation
soutenue et répétée des motivateurs peut
même mener la triste situation qui
impose et les vagues de suicides chez
orange et la poste mais nous pouvons
tous nous transformer en héros motivant
et inspirant
pouvons tous être motivé et transmettre
la motivation
nous pouvons tous être de neuro manager
qui rivalise avec les caresses des
oreillers au petit matin ce que j'ai
partagé avec vous aujourd'hui
eh bien il faut le faire pour soi même
donc prendre soin de son cerveau mais
aussi pour les autres
prendre soin de son entourage personnel
et professionnel concrètement ce que
j'ai partagé avec vous aujourd'hui c'est
la base de ce qu'on peut faire pour
travailler autour de la motivation
j'aurais aimé vous partagé par exemple
les postures qui vous permet d'être
motivé soi même mais vous savez le temps
est limité
si vous avez envie d'en savoir plus là
dessus ou sur la motivation en général
explorer ce que le neuro management peut
faire pour vous avec lui et avec moi si
vous le souhaitez la performance et le
bonheur sont à votre portée
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]